okay in this video we're going to look
at shomenuchi ikkyo nikkyo just means
first technique it's generally one of
the first things you learn the first
thing that you learn and it's one of the
hardest techniques it's prettier than
the last one you actually understand so
we're gonna break it down look at
different bits it's not just a case of
twisting the guys are about to hold on
to it so when you practice it try and
find the internal aspects of it rather
than the so I key that possibly is
basically here now it's usually shown as
a front weighty posture but the back
weighted posture here the transition
between the postures are very useful now
if you shifted a very strongly back
working position it's it's quite a bit
easier position to find the correct way
of standing so if you just sort of sit
back any old hariom the muscles here
will start screaming for mercy very soon
if you can arrange us hips and your bone
structure so it's self-supporting that's
kind of like a good place to start and
that's the that's how you get a stronger
posture from here you then transfer that
feeling into this ball from front weight
you posture its allows you to feel how
to get strong posture I think
anyway maybe doesn't that's why I think
it's because this is more uncomfortable
it's easier to find a comfortable
posture it's more obvious so what you
found this bust your age and transferred
to here as well your postures generally
I got to move from one posture to
another question another question okay
so I'm back waiting slot yet fairly
heavy back way things I'm going to move
forward I need to reserve if I'm forward
weighty than I do this movement
difficult to move so I'm going to the
back way put this striking move okay and
I'll still be back waited here at the
end of this then I will shift into the
front weight and I would step forward to
also turn here
this allows this don't open this hip up
wall and lay this leg then ladies waited
easy now to move into this posture boot
so each move return the flow between
posture just the step step step it's
emotional emotional when you're moving
from posture to posture it's if you move
incorrectly the detail parts the
technique how you move your arms well
you know how you lose a lot of it tends
to take care of itself so instead of
obsessing about the details and Aikido
especially while where Aikido can seem
very technical actually if you just move
correctly a lot of the detail stuff
dancers think about otherwise actually
just happens by itself because it
becomes a natural part of a movement and
becomes a logical thing to do it's
difficult not to do the correct move so
by getting postures in movement correct
you can see the bigger picture of the
technique you don't have to
obsess about the small things which is
kind of distracting in the best of times
and then it leads into similarities
between other techniques and really
Aikido
it's quite simple there's not that many
movements when you break it down into
very basic movements once you learn a
few movements
you've got the basis of the hollow
Aikido being simple doesn't mean it's
easy or easy to learn but it is in
essence a cetacean simple moves showing
the basic is a bit confusing because
shomenuchi is a strike to the head so
he's he's the dude shomenuchi he will be
striking straight down here with trying
to push the head back or ring it
sideways not actually so fanciest on the
head is your weapon within basic
shomenuchi ideas yet the noob so I moved
forward to here so what's that about
well it's a way of I believe of
simplifying the move so he is especially
first unlike Akio which is quite
preemptive technique so he is thinking
about doing show malucci's obviously the
posture of the shomenuchi it's just
about those shomenuchi and then I come
in here okay and that kind of fixes his
his thought patterns of this position so
he's not standing square on really good
I come in here he could do anything
so it sort of sets it up a bit and
that's really good as far like I'm
concerned how that works it's just a
simplification
he's trying to attack that I created the
attack because of what he's about to do
he's kind of strict in his lumens so
she's a way of starting the technique
now here he's he's thinking about
shomenuchi I'm going to react now you
see old news will bring his bag but we
gotta be way too friendly sort of way I
don't want to do it up yeah well even
just as easily take my own you know I
won't agree the position it gives me a
significant advantage everything I do is
set to position me the strongest
possible positions that you've read the
maximum amount of power leverage against
his minimum amount of power leverage
okay that's how I see how these
techniques work so first and goodness
I won't give him any clues I'm going to
strike it it's quite like a many you'll
strike with the boars tusks weights not
prescribed you've got this shape like a
boss puff it's straightforward but
powerful strike now he needs to think
that's gonna hit even in will extrude
that and I can strike here then he
blocks it here we're going to get
punished
fine so to point that I will now signs
and say and this this one these are one
that does all the work so I'm going to
come here it's the way to the side here
this just captures their from they are
like grip here and here I've got you off
balance
already I've used like the jello type
thrusting movement with the posture here
this is very much like a Joe and here I
can hand in I can now drop the hips here
put some pressure on down something like
a sauce right movement they can't
receive engage is back hand three
priorities straight for these and
usually with muscles it's a lot right
now from here I simply sent my kids I'm
going to slightly forward here to here
okay it also going to come straight here
my turn
it's foot outwards there with too much
because he's dropped all the way now
even if he's not sitting up off balance
I show you as they move you into the Kyo
position quite easily so if you resist
that no effort whatsoever okay
now you can't always risky or not
because it's just video but yeah
baby on finger how how's that possible
not the world's strongest finger we knew
by doing this movement I mean all these
muscles here he's kind of restricted to
you these back muscles slightly
stretched I'll switch off a lot of these
muscle groups so it's easy to go here
he's arm should align you smile boy
these are babies here to do the maximum
that got it so it's looking down I'm
going to balance if I keep this pressure
on here and I'm gonna kiss you my hips
yeah hey everybody drop a few drops on
following
bring the leg up down yeah okay now I
use my thumb as a spot but it's my leg
their legs open this light V so when
this comes down it's stretches on there
and I roll these arms back slightly
so the way don't baby lying do that okay
if you get any other angle he can
possibly break a lot pressure down so
he's on goes completely flat baby's arm
doesn't go completely flat so avoid the
screams of pain so just push it down a
little and I use hand blade against the
it's just both is joint here okay it's
not painful it just spins it it's more
of a test of your control yeah it's not
about breaking down or is he he's that
way to do that it's just pinning you
down there so you can loop it stretch
now
[Music]
shomenuchi
who ever talked about that on a previous
video so coming here and this side I
need three back leg up here it's like
you're flying so so here I now give you
this movement spiraling it down there at
least 180 degree turn
okay so similar feelings are strike a
back way this movement has hit and stuff
for happy flight under it now from here
I'll gripping I grip the elbow and a
grip the over the previous as well okay
if I get the angle correct it's easy
we're getting rolling tonight meso so if
I just continue this movement here keep
even the bounds of a circle that's
spiraling downward actually quiet
or if I I'm Paulie animal
she means some weird direction it's
going to get pretty difficult I need to
do is push these already off-balance
from lack push yeah I just keep pushing
in to the circle here back waiting here
below
yeah back waited and then okay this
is slight forward shift and it's
slightly turning stretches in here take
some balance
I think continuous move keeping the
weight on this leg takedown finishes
basically the same as the last one
[Music]
the opportunity strikes in here but not
for places in the museum it strikes
because the strikes make technique a bit
easy stew and with the aluminum tape
meet you on a big ball going to be
stable so you know the ribs down that's
not the examples away Tim easy okay so
that's shomenuchi ikkyo and I tell you
there okay so you learned something if
you're not familiar with this style of
eating slowly you know don't just
dismiss it have a look at it okay thanks
for watching and look out for other
videos later on
[Music]
you